hey good humans before we get into the
video we want to thank google five for
sponsoring this portion of the video
google fi is a phone plan by google it's
incredibly easy to get started and you
can do it all from your home there's no
activation fees and you don't have to
sign a contract they offer three plans
and you can either pay for the data you
use with google phys flexible plan or
choose between unlimited plans based on
your data usage i went with the simply
unlimited plan which is the most
affordable plan for unlimited data calls
and texts so dad you don't have to tell
me i'm using up all of our data anymore
because
it's unlimited it also has great privacy
and security features when you enable
google files vpn your online connection
is private and you have more protection
from hackers so even if i'm connected to
wi-fi at a coffee shop or an airport my
cellular and wi-fi traffic will be
encrypted you can bring your own phone
to any google fi plan which makes fi
accessible no matter what phone you have
thanks again to google 5 for sponsoring
this part of the video now let's get
into it and we're going to go boom like
this
i'm not slapping i'm not chopping you
want to be gliding this is hot
[Music]
hey i'm alyssa and i'm itoki and this is
expert amateur fraud a show where we try
to figure out who the expert is and
who's faking it and today we're going to
be interviewing three
drum roll please
whoa okay okay we're about to eat good
oh my gosh okay fancy schmancy now it's
real it's hard to tell whether or not
someone's like a pro or fake but i've
also seen the movie ratatouille so i
don't know i feel like i'm pretty
knowledgeable about this to be honest
with you and that was like that's i feel
weird that i haven't seen that oh
interesting yeah
[Music]
thank you so much for coming to my house
oh i love your house it's beautiful
pretty spacious open concept hi i'm
shawn hi
and i have for you a thai shepherd's pie
oh a shepherd's pie i love a little
shepherd it's high shepherd's pie it
rhymes so what are the ingredients of
this one so the base is ground beef
there's eggplant peas carrots you know
the thai comes in from the thai chili
paste it might be a little spicy okay
okay that's all right yeah okay looking
at me
i made it because i kind of wanted to
tie it to what i want to teach you guys
i apply it to it
[Laughter]
that was a very generous look
um i wanted to tie this in to what i
wanted to teach you which is how to
build flavor my philosophy is that
cooking is a language you know so the
more you know about it the more you can
say what you want with food cooking is
like its own language there's all like
tbsp
what does that mean
is there yeah is there an eating
technique oh yeah for sure how it is on
your spoon kind of matters you don't
want it really yeah you don't want too
much of the beef you don't want too much
of it oh okay okay you kind of want a
whole experience you've seen her out of
tui right of course yeah it feels weird
you haven't seen that so you know how he
eats that strawberry and cheese and
there's those notes yes i want you to
really think about the flavors in there
like i want to be encompassing flavor i
appreciate that you want to see the
sweetness you want to feel a little
tartness from
the tomato-based curry
i feel the spice a little bit there's a
little butter in there for lusciousness
oh my gosh this is amazing
this is the real deal that's a great
comic yeah i feel like they all
complement each other really well
i always emphasize trying new things you
know there's so much food out there why
would you want to eat only grilled
cheese for the rest of your life when
you could have a thousand different
kinds of grilled cheese with all the
cheeses out there you know
welcome in thank you join the party
please what's your name my name is gill
myself
oh and he got an onion can you guess
what we're going to do
chopped onions yes are we specifically
we are learning knife skills because if
you don't have that you're not going to
be able to cook anything
are we going to cry
um only if you fail i definitely will
cry yeah i cry like profusely so the
first step is you got to know how to
pick up your knife and you're already
failing holding it by blade
come on
okay so why don't you guys put down your
knives we're going to pick them up
together put down your oh
so you're going to grab it by the handle
go for it that's classic
now walk your fingers forward
your thumb should be actually on the
side of the blade and you're right
wrapped around this way this is like
pull billiards
sure yeah first step is you take this
side
cut
that's all you need to get off this side
all you need to get rid of is this
little part right there right side up go
halfway down
boom like that
so the next now watch this look the skin
just comes right off that's super easy
super easy okay it's real that's
actually great i i'm genuinely thinking
about all the time that i have never i
have yeah i've never seen an onion like
bare naked like that
i've never seen
no i've never seen it's like naked body
what do you do you cook with the skin
off yeah or you're not supposed to
oh boy we might need a little more time
yeah find the flat side
take the knife the onion is round so you
don't want to just go down
and we're going to go boom like this
and you see i'm not i'm not slapping i'm
not chopping you want to be gliding this
is hot
now are there onions in the thing you
cooked for us today yes oh there are
oh my gosh
okay what do you call this so these are
vietnamese style fresh rolls okay so
inside we got some fresh herbs lettuce
cilantro mint crispy pork belly grilled
onions and then this is a peanut butter
chili garlic sauce it's kind of this is
intimidating in a sense because i feel
like in a restaurant you would never eat
this right in front of the chef okay
here goes i'm gonna bon appetit
oh yeah get it a little cilantro out of
the mouth
yeah don't sleep on that sauce just keep
you got to keep like pouring it in there
even though i have a peanut allergy
[Music]
girl this is amazing yeah gil has a
really like confident presence which is
needed in the kitchen to me this is like
five stars
[Music]
i'd say the first thing that will tell
you that somebody doesn't know what
they're doing in the kitchen is looking
at their knife skills which is why i
decided to use that as my
skill because when you get into
professional cooking knife skills is the
first thing that you learn
[Music]
[Applause]
this hello
a salmon dish
and a bok choy with mushrooms
this looks so good you guys are hungry
oh my god wait what's your name my name
is lillian lillian thank you so much for
coming thank you for having me what made
you choose these dishes these are my
favorites um it's also something simple
to make because i feel like sometimes
people are like oh cooking is too hard
right but it's actually this is simple
it looks complicated trust me simple
ingredients this looks delicious here i
have ginger garlic mushrooms bok choy
all that has to be processed oh and
onions that you probably already have
you know
let me tell you
you said this is something that your
family has done before and then you're
kind of taking honor okay yeah is that
what a lot of your dishes are do you
think like i think so
you're like i'm not picky so this is
going to be impossible for me to
decipher who's i can't belie i need to
like give you 20 dollars
good i love that even like restaurants
aren't this good look i feel like i'm
eating like a home-cooked gourmet meal
oh like it feels like i'm in your house
with you and your family
if i just open the crown up and he's
like walking
actually they cooked it
maybe maybe you never know i'm
shook and i can't believe that you're
just here with me
you didn't need this delicious food
it's also super healthy which is great
yes that's also something i like i think
food should be it should feel good it
should taste good yeah feel good tastes
good yeah that also sounds like
something a chef would say
no really great job
super delicious
i'm good this is going to be so hard
deciding who the heck
is the real ship cause like so far i'm
like everybody
[Laughter]
food is my love language i love to cook
for friends family members anyone who
i'm able to invite into my home the way
that people interact with me when they
taste my food and they're just so happy
and they're like wow you cook this for
me i'm like why not yeah i cook this for
you and i just love that feeling i
literally have never been this confused
the last time i was this confused when i
was trying to learn multiplication
do you have any instincts like right now
from the get-go i do have like sort of
instincts tell me lillian was the
sweetest but in my mind i think she just
talked too much about kind of like
family dishes
which made me think that maybe she is
the fraud her dish was incredible but
yeah you know i have situations like
that too where i'm like oh i made this
because my mom made yes absolutely so
it's like you know also that's the thing
like lillian could literally own
like a family-owned restaurant and be
the chef like that's literally a thing
that's true my initial thought
was that sean was the expert yeah the
way they talked about all of the flavor
profile stuff
what did you think of gill
onion gil it was good but maybe we have
to peel back the layers of the onion and
we find out that he's an amateur wow
[Music]
it's been so long uh we're outnumbered
so if we're wrong
we're gonna get
cut
we think
the expert
is sean right the flavor conversation
and the layers and the there was just
something different about the way they
kind of addressed their dish and i'm so
sorry
if it's not true
oh my gosh i actually like okay now i
have a feeling that we were wrong on
everything yeah
we thought the amateur was
gill the onion
connoisseur yes which now possibly is an
expert but we thought prior it was
amateur
nice nice
last but not least last but not least
hello lillian we think you're the frog
but we're zero for two so we could be
completely the reason why we said that
was because we were like oh it felt just
kind of like
the food was amazing but we were like oh
this is like just kind of like her
family dishes and we both said oh yeah
we can make like our family classics i
don't know i feel like we could get this
one you think yeah
oh my god i told you yes let's go
okay you got so gill yes
you're the expert i'm assuming
i've been in the food service for over
10 years i've been out of culinary
school about six years or so and i've
been working for about five years as a
private chef when i was in culinary
school there were a lot of people that
signed up thinking it was just gonna be
a fun cooking class and those people all
dropped out when you realize that you're
gonna be there hours and hours a day as
long as you're willing to do all that
you can do it but it's not for everybody
john amateur yep what does that look
like i am in school for food science oh
okay you made it so casually you're like
yeah i just cook a lot at home
so i actually started school with the
idea to get into nursing a semester in i
found out about food science and these
are the people that
work on like your favorite flavor of
cereal you know the research that goes
into that you guys are all amazing yeah
it's great and thanks for sharing your
dish too lillian it's good thank you
it's part of your family i said we got
to experience that that's great my
grandma loves to cook i think she should
start a restaurant my mom took after her
so i definitely learned from them and
being at home during the day now did you
actually cook the food that you brought
today i did yeah you want
you're not a fraud
the distinction between fraud and
amateur for the purpose of the show
be in the professional experience or
like the educational experience because
i'm not going to school for
cooking
i never took lessons for any of these
culinary tips that i know or tricks
versus for me it's like a hobby in
eighth grade i developed the eating
disorder
i had anorexia nervosa and just it was
really really bad i didn't really
appreciate my mom's cooking
but she put so much love and time and
energy to make sure that i was healthy
and
okay so to me like food is
it's so much more than just
a meal you know
i just am really grateful that um my
relation to food has improved whatever
motive you have whatever relationship
you have to food i just really pray that
it is a healthy one and it's one that
fulfills you and
makes you feel
joy that's all just to feel joy around
food
[Music]
you